Three most feared presidents in the world.
Number three
Vladimir Putin.
Widely regarded as one of the most powerful
and influential leaders in the world,
he has a reputation for being ruthless,
authoritarian
and unpredictable.
He drives around in a presidential limo
that is built like a tank
with its own oxygen and assault rifles,
with 7,000 highly trained officers protecting him.
24 seven. Number two
Kim Jong Un.
One of the most
isolated and secretive leaders in the world,
he rules over a nuclear armed state
that is often at odds with the international community.
He moves with a retinue of 12 bodyguards
inside a heavily armoured Mercedes Benz S600,
which has two engines,
rockets and various communication systems.
Before revealing the number one,
remember to subscribe and like the video.
Number one Xi Jin Ping.
The leader of the most populous
and second largest economy in the world.
He has consolidated his power by abolishing term limits,
cracking down on descent,
and expanding China's global influence.
He oversees a vast military and security apparatus
with a budget of $261 billion in 2023.